how did you uh originally link up with
cardi [ __ ] that [ __ ] was just random as
hell
I was sitting at the crib one day and
then like honestly I got a phone call
and it was his army and he took the
phone and it was him wow and then after
that he said he was coming to Atlanta
went to the studio
that was that after that what year was
this this was like probably like two
years ago two years ago yeah this is uh
pre a whole lot of red or this is in
that in the middle of that yeah era yeah
would you consider yourself someone who
was like influenced by cardi prior to
working with them
influenced I guess I would say
definitely I ain't gonna lie I love
cardi like outside of him being you're
my brother but it's like he's as a fan
yeah yeah 100 so I was [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] so when you hit me up I was like
down in brazy but I feel like everybody
[ __ ] with everything like he's the way
he met me was like he was [ __ ] with
my [ __ ] so it's like you know what I'm
saying what do you remember what song it
was he heard that was like yeah it was
oh yeah nice it was just song off my
album called broke his heart broken
hearts it's uh the song's called oh yeah
it sounds pretty fire though I like
performing it
um
which album are you taking die lit or
whole lot of red
it's crazy because you know I had this
conversation
I stand on a daily me too like okay but
wholehearted is a very great album it's
not ads to none I'm not saying nothing
like that but my personal favorite album
is valid yeah so personally for me dial
it was dope yeah whole lot of red was
the one album in my entire life as a
hip-hop fan where I was just like I'm
old wow that's crazy as [ __ ] like I'm
getting old because I'm like I mean some
of the Beats were crazy yeah but just
some of that [ __ ] I think it came out
like Christmas Eve or something wild
like that or Christmas yeah because I
remember driving to Walgreens was the
only place that was open and I was like
man this [ __ ] this [ __ ] on and I
remember I hit play on that [ __ ]
and I was like
[ __ ] is going on all right I'm I'm gonna
say like I don't think you should judge
yourself for being old but what a whole
lot of red is is forward like it's like
I think I I only listen to it once you
should listen to it again you should 100
listen I feel like I got enough and then
maybe what you should do before you
listen to it again is watch it live and
then go listen to it again I've seen him
live so the live picture show is crazy
that's the album no the live shows it's
a it's a lot going on but this is what
I'm saying next time listen to that I'm
thinking that maybe I should listen to
it on on some like some shrooms you feel
me yeah you gotta get into it I I think
I do have to get into it for sure you
got it like I'm not into it you gotta
like like it's like that's what I'm
saying is forward like music now
personally I would say like if rap
before it was like lyrics and there's
rappers and this is what rappers do it's
more of like like a worldly thing now so
like my Playboy cardi fan lives in
Playboy Cardi's World anything that he
does they will understand a destroy
lonely fan is the same way and so on and
so forth now I think so